this program is brought to you by Emory
University
good afternoon I'm here to stop your
enjoyment briefly some of you may
recognize me because I was in the
hallway recruiting people to come into
this room telling you is the best of the
sessions so now we have to we have to
live up to it I'm Jim Curran Dina the
Rollins School of Public Health and I am
honored and delighted to be the
moderator of the session today we're
under a semi strict schedule I get five
minutes to introduce the topic and the
people each of them then we'll speak for
10 minutes roughly and then there'll be
30 minutes for all of us to go at each
other and have some fun but we want to
protect that 30 minutes because we know
you will have lots of comments and
questions the first thing I'd like to do
is thank all of you trustees and alumni
for all you do for emery it is so
important to us and to our future and
I've been the Dean for 15 years I think
somebody forgot that I was here kept me
on is Dean but I've been watching Emory
over the last 15 years and from I my
perch at CDC for many years before that
and the growth in the quality and
excellence of Emery has been very very
inspiring so that is because of the
support we get from the trustees in the
alumni and of course we hope
particularly our excellent faculty and
students when I was reflecting on Emery
in the developing world I was thinking
about my lifetime this is something we
all do when we get to be a certain age
and we think about how things are
different than they used to be when i
was in college i went to a private
school and and a lot of us had a chance
maybe to study abroad for a little while
usually in a european country and most
of the immigrants i knew or from Ireland
or Poland or maybe maybe a Germany or
some place it was not a very diverse
country and it took a long time to get
information and it seemed like we
measured impacts in months or days or
something but it's so different now when
the extensive diversity in Atlanta
remember moving to Atlanta in 78 and I
thought everybody was in African
American or white American there seemed
to be nobody from any other country
everybody was from
the United States and now of course
we're from everywhere and we don't
identify even by the shade of our skin
anymore but we identify and much more
rich diversity which i think is a
wonderful thing but it's a change we are
very fortunate I think and we also have
had a diversity in our influences we see
it used to be only infectious diseases
my area of interest crossed borders and
they still do as a matter of fact our
vegetables travel more than I did when I
was young and and they come from all
over the world and we have to be
vigilant about that but now our
lifestyle patterns emerge and so that
China and India and Latin America
fortunately eat an exercise like we do
in America and they've become obese and
diabetic but just like we have and
that's even without crossing borders
where we have diverse influences We are
fortunate I think to have faculty who
are ahead of the game who not only are
people it can help teach the students
about the diversity of the world but can
participate in understanding and
changing the diversity of the world and
we have three really great people here
from three different schools so I was
trying to think what are they have in
common as I look at their CVS ray
martorell Lynn Sibley and Peter Roberts
they're all great teachers and they've
been loud at at Emory for their teaching
and mentoring ability they're also all
great researchers and it published very
very widely and extensively the other
thing is they all work across schools
and departments two of them have a lil
here faculty appointments in three
different schools have been one in four
schools and they all work across schools
and then finally they all travel a lot
and that means they have to do that to
do their work so they really have worked
in the developing countries so these are
the three people in order I know ray
martorell the best because rain and I
had been at Emory together in the
Rollins School of Public Health and I
was fortunate enough to convince him
that he should be our department chair
in the Hubert
a global health 13 years ago every year
you come into my office and say is my
time up yet because he came to Emory and
was recruited to Emory as a Woodruff
professor and he is somebody I would put
up to anyone to be an example of what
the endowed professorships that mr.
Woodruff gave us can do for the
University and for the world raise the
phenomenal guy he's a faculty member in
public health he's an assistant director
of the Global Health Institute he is
also jointly appointed in medicine the
Graduate School and an anthropology is a
PhD in biological anthropology and he is
the Woodruff professor of international
nutrition and global health he was our
first memory the present president's
Advisory Committee during that first met
first committee when it was when it was
born his research has been in maternal
and child nutrition he has more than 300
peer-reviewed publications and is well
known throughout the world for his work
he's received many awards I'll just
mentioned three he was elected the
Institute of Medicine of the National
Academy of Sciences in 2002 he received
the Marian creekmore award for
international health here at Emory in
2008 and then about one month ago the
richest man in the world Carlos Slim the
Carlos Slim foundation awarded him the
Lifetime Achievement research award the
highest award given in Latin America for
research for some irony about the
richest man in the world giving an award
to someone who was life has been devoted
to the poorest people in the world and
then Sibley is tremendously terrific
also she began her career as a midwife
and a nurse got a PhD also an
anthropology and his associate professor
of Nursing and global health in the in
the School of Nursing in school of
public health and also as it is
appointed in the Department of
Anthropology in the College of Arts and
Sciences she's the director of Emrys
maternal and newborn health center in
Ethiopia have funded by a three-year
grant from the gates foundation of over
eight million dollars the largest grant
ever received and by the Woodruff School
of Nursing in addition she is the
founding director of the Emory center
for
research and I can't read my own writing
terrible and maternal and neonatal
survival she's been a long-term
consultant to waho UNICEF ins fellow
american academy in nursing and in 2007
she received the atlanta business
chronicle health care heroes award Peter
Roberts is really a cool guy and he's
the only one that got the memo on how to
dress free this is his school and I see
him most often in the school because he
has volunteered for many years to
co-chair and co-director Martin Luther
King award ceremony that we have with
the School of Business every year the
Peters PhD is an organizational analysis
following degrees in economics and he's
an associate professor of organization
and management here he also is directing
his interest in entrepreneurship and
organizational performance now towards
social good and social diversity we
recruited him away from Columbia
University now he's done a global
feasibility study right now with student
interns to develop a world-class up from
logic facility in Honduras and he heads
guz Weta's social enterprise initiative
Peter Roberts is no fool he's not only
smart but he's no fool and why do I say
that it's because he has a proposal to
establish a poverty fighting wine
industry in Ethiopia and for that he's
reserved also many awards and honors I
only mentioned three one is the Don
Kiowa for excellence in because what a
business school in 2010 but these to
prove how wise he is in 2008 he got the
prize for the best research from the
American Association of wine Economist's
in a 2007 he got the the prize liquid
assets prize
so we have three great people and then
we're opening for discussion we begin
with Ray martorell thanks Jim for a
great introduction I didn't know you
liked me so much it probably means
someone will get a big raise I'd like to
talk to you about the importance of
nutrition during the first thousand days
this is a topic that has interested me
during my entire career and I'm
presenting on behalf of many colleagues
at Emory you know a students and faculty
as well as elsewhere this first thousand
days are really a window of
vulnerability in human development it's
a very critical phase and there are many
reasons one is that during this phase
there are very high in nutritional
requirements and in part this is due to
fade rapid rates of physical growth but
also brain development in young children
are also very susceptible to infections
and they're fully dependent on others
for care and in developing countries
mothers are very busy they work very
hard in and outside the home and often a
you know children are left young
children babies are left in the care of
siblings sometimes with disastrous
consequences and one of the consequences
of child malnutrition is mortality a
little less than three million children
die each year due to child malnutrition
in poor countries and this represents
around twenty eight percent of all child
is but I really been interested with my
colleagues on another question you know
what happens to those who don't die what
happens to those who survive how do they
who they grow up to be are they impair
in capacities and this question we you
know
answering through a number of studies
but I thought I highlight two of them
and one is a study in Guatemala where we
are doing a follow-up of nutrition
experiment that was conducted between
1969 and 77 by the institute of
nutrition of Central American Panama
Inca and the second one is we're
focusing it on the great famine in China
of 1959-60 one that was associated with
mouse a great leap forward policies tell
you a little bit about the being cup
longitudinal study it was an experiment
it wasn't a public health nutrition
program it was a very controlled
situation in which two villages receive
a nutritious supplement to villages a
controlled drink and all four receive a
preventive and curative medical care if
this is a very well-known study and it
improved survival in improved birth
weight it improve child growth but only
in the first three years of life and for
a number of years really decades we've
been involved in follow-up studies of
former participants in this study and
this is the only study in the world to
assess the long-term impact of a
nutrition intervention during this early
critical phase in adults
and here are some examples of findings
at around 32 years of age we find that
you know it those who received improve
nutrition have Greater stature created
muscle mass an improved capacity to do
work there are also differences in very
important human capital measures like
schooling and IQ in men increase wages
and we also find an impact on the
subsequent generation better child
growth in the women of in the children
of women exposed to improve nutrition
I'd like to tell you a little bit about
the effects on wages and annual income
this is defining that has drawn the most
attention from our study first we find
that improved nutrition in the first
thousand days but not later it has to be
given in this window critical window
increase wages and in annual incomes in
terms of wages the effect was 67 cents
per hour additional it this represents
at forty six percent increase over
average wages in annual incomes went up
by 870 represented an increase of
twenty-six percent in wages
a little bit about the Chinese famine
this is the largest family in human
history with up to 60 million people a
dying we use funding from the Global
Health Institute seed money and we have
been conducting what we call secondary
data analysis these analyses of data
collected for other purposes and we find
that exposure to the famine during this
critical phase it's linked to shorted
adult stature a greater overweight and
hypertension to risk of mental health
illness and again generational effects
influences on birth weight of the next
generation and this seed funding from
the Global Health Institute has allowed
us to prepare a very strong a proposal
for NIH we're planning a large
comprehensive study in china and finally
I'd like to present to you another
effort that's representative of what we
do in the School of Public Health in
other parts of Henry we do research but
we also get really involved in very
applied work in the context of programs
and this is a an involvement in an
ambitious five-year project to improve
both the design and delivery the quality
of a package of interventions aim at
women and children aim at the first 1000
days and this is taking place in Bihar
India Bihar is the state up in the north
right the Bologna pal bihar is a very
populated state under million people and
it's among the poorest in india has the
worst health and nutrition indicators in
the country
this project is funded by the Gates
Foundation and the key partner is care
and our role at Emory is to provide
expertise in nutrition and illustrative
of what we do with many projects we
involve students and at this moment in
PR we have six students from Emory and
this is my final slide and I'd like to
make a couple points about the impact
that our research has had on policies
and programs a for example it has
influenced along with the work of others
be thinking of the World Bank and in
2006 the World Bank wrote this very
influential monograph it's called
repositioning nutrition as central to
developing and they don't mean human
development they mean economic
development and in it they make the
point that nutrition is not only a
matter of welfare or Human Rights not
only a matter of the responsibility of
the state to provide for children but
also is nutritionist economic investment
an engine of economic growth and I think
what our work shows is that to be most
effective you know this investments in
nutrition and women and children have to
be targeted first of all to the poorest
of the poor but also targeted to the
first thousand days because the critical
to human development thank you very nice
right I have to a segue from Ray
actually when I was a graduate student I
studied ray my my pcs and biological
anthropology also and my advisor was a
great admirer array of rays work and and
very much encouraged us to study him and
so he's been one of my heroes as well
I'm gonna see if I can figure out how to
do this
help is anyway help is on the way that's
good thank you all for coming really
appreciate it i know you had options and
we're very delighted that you're here to
share with us yep that's it great
yeah I'm going to take a risk here
normally I speak with slides and I use
them as a crutch to keep me on time but
I know I have a really good time keeper
here in gym so I trust that he will do
the needful ray talked a lot about the
first thousand days and the critical
preconception all period and post
conceptual period for for growth and
development I want to take our lens even
further focused to the period in and
around the time of birth this is the
area where i've spent about the last 30
years of my life working and we have
been really fortunate to have funding
from the Gates Foundation to actually
further this work in a way that may
allow us to take it to scale nationally
in a place where there's a great need
for this a half a million women died
during childbirth every year mostly in
developing countries is over ninety-nine
percent in developing countries and
around two million newborns die so if
you look at this across the board the
the ratios from maternal death reflect
what the US looked like in about the
turn of the century around 1500 per
100,000 live births so this really of
all the public health statistics
reflects one of the greatest disparities
that you will see and knowing what we
know today no woman should die giving
birth we know what to do what we don't
know is how to deliver the care
particularly in contexts that our rural
where health systems are developing and
access to care for women or even
cultural norms around accessing care
really are weak or non-existent in
Ethiopia specifically about 22,000 women
die every year and a hundred thousand
newborns died during and around the time
of birth
much progress has been made and in
Ethiopia under the leadership of the
National Ministry of Health Ethiopia has
developed a health extension program
which is modeled on agricultural
extension program that many of you may
have heard of and this is to posted now
posted 35,000 health extension workers
which are young women with a tenth grade
education they're trained in about 16
packages of primary health care and
maternal and newborn care is just one of
the many packages and they are posted to
/ health post which is the most
peripheral unit in the health system to
take care of the populations there this
effort has been going well it's about
five years old they've got health post
built and most of the districts
throughout the country they have health
extension workers deployed but what they
don't have our women using these
services and they also don't have health
extension workers who feel confident and
competent in their ability to deliver
services in particular maternal and
newborn health care Ethiopia is a place
where ninety percent of women give birth
at home mostly with family members and
sometimes traditional birth attendants
depending on what region of the country
that you're in we are working in
collaboration we're under the umbrella
of the Ministry of Health working in
collaboration with Jon Snow research and
training institute which is based in in
boston they have been working in
ethiopia for now twelve years have a
large number of programs in country so
they're very strong in country
implementing partner we're also working
with university research company based
in Bethesda Maryland we have staff hired
through that agency working with us in
country and we have a large Ethiopian
staff most of our team is in Ethiopia we
have 26 on staff we're in two regions
and within each of those regions six
districts and within each slice of that
reflecting the different tiers of the
health system so what we're trying to do
is a demonstration project of a
community oriented strategy that will
actually improve the quality and
reliability of care that mothers and
babies get in and around the time of
birth and also that there is referral to
a health facility if there's one for the
referral to take place that that happens
a reliable way essentially we're working
at the interface from the most
peripheral health system unit to the
community in this space we have three
major activities that were engaged in
one is a community maternal and newborn
health care training program and if you
imagine childbirth education preparation
in the US where during the latter parts
of pregnancy women and their in their
husbands or couples go for for education
and preparation for birth and labor and
birth and early postnatal period this is
a very similar concept except that we're
really focusing on how to do clean safe
delivery how to resuscitate a newborn if
necessary how to prevent bleeding too
much bleeding how to conduct a safe
referral when you have to build a litter
you have to round up people you have to
carry people you have to raise money so
it's it's really trying to look at okay
what is the best kind of birth
preparedness and complication readiness
we can have in a context where home
birth is a norm and referral facilities
are widely dispersed the idea behind
this program and this is building on the
work that we've done for the last 20
years through the American College of
nurse midwives and and that is it's not
enough to to have a biomedical approach
to training and that this is how you
should do things people come with their
own ways of doing things their own norms
particularly in childbirth so it's
really engaging women and their family
caregivers who will be present at birth
on what they already know and do during
labor and birth and how they manage
complications and then what a train by a
medical practitioner would do and then
negotiating what would you be willing to
do and then we have pictorial this is
pictorial learning we have pictorial
what we call take action cards that have
the problem on one side in the back side
you have action steps to take so assume
that we've built skills in terms of how
to do safe clean delivery and referral
it's not always enough we need to know
when women are pregnant we need to
identify them get them into the training
get them into antenatal care we need to
know when labor starts so that a higher
level of skilled provider can get into
the
certainly for postnatal care because
right now postnatal care is about six
percent in Ethiopia it's quite low we've
been receiving a you know postnatal care
within the first 24 to 48 hours so all
of these systems that support reliable
care to support that content of care are
also part of this program we're working
with volunteer community teams on what
we call a continuous collaborative
quality improvement model Emory is
actually emory healthcare as part of a
collaborative for quality improvement in
our health facilities this is taking
that approach to the community level and
this is novel about this project no one
has done that before so we're learning
how to work with communities and
community volunteers and stakeholders to
get involved in those processes that
make sure that the care happens these
two activities are supported by behavior
change communication activities that are
based on local strategies in terms of
poetry contests song drama using all the
local means and we found for example in
our training program we have the
pictorial cards but everyone commits the
steps of managing hemorrhage to memory
and to song and so they sing it and so
we have elders in the community who can
sing the steps of stopping bleeding so
sour team really is engaged in doing
that finally the approach is really
because we're working at district level
we're trying to link the different
levels of the health system so we have
the Regional Health Bureau the zonal
Health Bureau the district health Bureau
and then below that engaging all of
these people in the planning process in
the quality improvement process with the
idea that at the end of the day we'll
have a district that is actually able to
do continuous quality improvement here
we're focusing on a very difficult area
which is birth to 48 hours and how to
improve survival in that window but if
we're successful then this can be used
for any aspect of public health or any
other kind of community effort for that
matter is a systemic approach so in any
event we are sort of halfway through
this process now we are in
aged very actively in the community our
team is in the field a lot we are
holding learning sessions every every
quarter the teams identify ideas about
you know their own creative solutions to
identifying pregnancy identifying or
labor notification follow-up and so
forth and then they test their ideas
looking at outcome measures are they
really increasing the number of women
who are identified and so forth and then
we'll compare across all of the
districts in the project and look for
the most robust ideas and come up with a
package of care that includes the
evidence-based maternal and newborn care
practices but also the processes of
getting that care into the home what we
hope to see at the end of the day is a
successful model in our demonstration
regions that is adopted by the Federal
Ministry of Health and the regional
health bureaus and that we are able to
build a platform to take this to scale
nationally and that is really the end
product of this particular grant is a
scale-up plan for that we hope to see
health said this health system in
particular having the capacity for
continuous quality improvement and that
they're able to actually transfer these
skills to other kinds of areas and then
this model actually could be applied in
other settings I feel incredibly
fortunate to be engaged in this and and
really appreciate the effort of Emory
and the Global Health Institute in
particular for working with us as we
were developing this grant proposal we
have in the process of this in order to
position Emory gone through a
year-and-a-half process of Emory being
registered as an NGO is a legal entity
in Ethiopia and we are in the process of
learning how we actually higher national
staff in Ethiopia so that we can have a
broader preference not a presence not
just for this program but also for other
Emory activities in Ethiopia and to
really solidify a relationship with with
the Ministry of Health and other
partners I failed to mention one of our
partners and that is Addis Ababa
University they are they're a very
strong partner this project is also
and provided a wonderful opportunity for
student engagement last summer we had
nine students in the field with us this
summer we have four and they cross the
the disciplines at Emory and from
undergraduate to postdoc students so we
are they they're incredible they further
our work and they also meet their own
research needs and they're a joy to have
so thank you so what a humbling
experience not only underdressed but
considerably late to the party I I don't
have a career to talk about and a long
track record what we're doing here in
the business school in kind of that
relates to this theme is actually only
about two and a half or so years old we
decided to work together and develop
something that we're calling social
enterprise at goizueta and it's kind of
housed on a small but growing belief
that you can take business acumen and
market-based solutions and apply them
not solely to the making of money but
also connect to the creation of positive
social impacts and so part about you
know that overall agenda has taken us to
different parts around the world and
it's been an unbelievably exciting if
not short yeah so far journey so
hopefully it will get together again
about five years from now and we'll
start talking about of a litany have
work done but I'll just tell you kind of
how we're approaching the problem it's
not surprising that there are
individuals that are interested in
making money in developing countries so
the issue that we tend to focus on is
how you might use business acumen and
market solutions to actually kind of
work on behalf of the individuals whose
lives you want to improve
it's a challenge a lot of business
activity but not necessary a lot of kind
of appropriate business orientations so
you know how do you kind of start in the
context of a business school that's
growing and in a field that's also kind
of growing and the first thing you think
I think you need three pieces in general
you need a context to create
introductions and exposures so you got
this kind of this general business
acumen that you develop but before you
have anything useful to say you have to
kind of be highlighted to the fact that
might be an issue a problem or an
opportunity though here if you stand
kind of too far away from things you get
a little bit distant a little bit
arrogant alright so the first thing that
we need to do is we need to kind of
bring ourselves to the spot where people
are perceiving you know interesting
opportunities and that you know has
happening in a surprisingly kind of
positive numbers here because Emery's
just a real awesome place to have a
business school or people are saying wow
if someone could figure out how to do X
here yeah that will be fabulous so our
direct exposures but more often than not
the people that we meet are saying do
you think you might be able to help us
think about get this kind of issue so
the introductions and exposures second
piece that's challenging is creativity
because you do believe that there's
business acumen that can be used here
but it's not business as usual so
someone's got to look at the problem and
think the same but different you know at
the same time so you want to kind of
encourage that appropriate creativity
and then I think the final piece that's
that's probably the biggest challenge
not just for the business global the
world at large is once you have these
cool ideas how do you engender the
commitment right the same kind of
commitment that you get for kind of like
individual economic agents working on
their own behalf too so to say I'm going
to stick with this particular venture
idea for five ten years down the road so
engendering the commitment so we're
doing a few things around here that are
kind of working under those three prongs
of you get exposure you try to be
creative and then you try to engender
commitment and a couple have been
alluded to already projects i think is
my favorite part of the job so imagine
kind of transitioning from doing kind of
consulting work which is always kind of
that work that you did for money you
take that kind of thing you think you
know you're good at and you apply this
on business problem but you you apply it
to problems like somebody comes along
and says you know what they should be
growing wine in Ethiopia
yeah the environmental preconditions are
there the market preconditions are their
experiments are going on wouldn't it be
awesome right if you could help Prime
that industry right so that when the
wine industry takes off the individuals
that might be the most knowledgeable and
then potentially the most benefiting
from this thing we're actually the
farmers yeah they're currently had
access to the land all right now you
start off of that thing and yes point
that I've actually done some research in
the wine industry over the last 12 years
and it's kind of a sign that you might
be in the right spot this is can you go
to Ethiopia and think about what would
it take to develop a economically viable
line cluster but one that had kind of a
distribution of returns it made you
excited it was actually kind of working
now you look at it this kind of
generates a few sneers when you start
but it's kind of it's it's it's kind of
awesome opportunity because it's an
unbelievable catch proper to get it
right but also wine grapes grow on lands
that basically are useful here for
anything else so these kind of these
preconditions are there you go visit and
all of a sudden you realize you have the
layton entrepreneurs around there like
folks that basically work in the
equivalent of investment banking over
there going I would buy a winery I'd buy
grapes for sure right if only they were
wrong you know here and so you got the
climatic preconditions all you really
need is a plan so I took a bunch of
students and we went over and we work
for about five minutes five months and
that included a couple of weeks on the
ground in five minutes I wish
it's quick and I should come back with
this idea like an unbelievably
optimistic plan that says you know you
can do this there's a lot of folks with
resources around the world that are
really really interested in kind of
helping out what would be cooperative
farm just helping get into this
particular space problem is is that the
Rose ours is all distributed all over
the place the guys that Cornell are
interested Davis is interested
stellenbosch is interest how do you
bring them all together so we have this
kind of report that talks about
potential and this is the part as an
instructor where I get jaz one of my MBA
students you know said listen when I
graduate I think what I want to do is
actually devote my career to these kind
of projects right so sanjo starts a
nonprofit organization and then takes
the plan that's now trying to see the
plan of action so she's got a few folks
heading back down to September to do
site selection and kind of work with
local farmers to get that next piece of
the puzzle it's still you know five ten
years off if it kicks right the numbers
for the farmers are awesome in this
particular case and my kind of fantasy
yo down the road is like 10 years when I
would come back and look at and says
yeah actually there is alright this kind
of this economic engine that's based on
kind of knowledge based agriculture and
it's it's actually benefiting the right
people so kind of excited about that
we're on the start of something that
where someone came up different you know
kind of idea we're doing kind of
Ophthalmology work on a pro bono basis
in Honduras the problem really has got
great surgeons yo down in Honduras a
latent demand for what we do but you
know there's gaps in there in terms of
creating the right kind of facility or
context where some of the revenue that
could be spent in a kind of in Honduras
might be able to stay in Honduras and
actually provoke get more energy care
now this particular model is kind of in
quotation marks revolutionary but folks
look like they might be prepared to
commit six seven eight million dollars
right investing in a facility you have
down there of the right type questions
but they need the plan so I'm going to
be working for the next five months with
a trip down to Honduras to summer with a
different set of students trying to see
whether or not we can draw the right
kind of combination of pieces so it said
again five ten years from now you're
looking at kind of an interesting
market-based piece you have to solving
kind of an important
so I get to do that kind of stuff we're
going to be doing more of it as I think
we develop a bit of a track record yeah
down here and we show the folks that we
can actually kind of you know provide
that important creativity I think we'll
be doing more work we're going out of
Nicaragua on a regular basis trying to
expose folks to some poverty and some
opportunities and you know four hours
away second poorest country in the
Western Hemisphere and the exciting
thing about this we give them exposures
one of my students is on the board of an
organization kind of working down there
another group of students are heading
back to do follow on work and that's the
kind of thing that from that program I
desperately want to see happen right as
you kind of invest in your own success
coming out of Emory what you have in you
is this ability to kind of take some of
that surplus around the edges right and
actually kind of see cool and
interesting market-based things done
down in Central America and then the
final piece I've got a ways to go I've
spent 12 years researching you know wine
industry it is somewhat more energizing
at the end of the day you know the
critical debates in the wine economics
field is does Robert Parker's palate
really reflect get the objective value
of wine and to be honest there's some
fun stuff in there but at the end of the
day you're going does it really matter
right so some of the projects I get to
work on right now same set of idea but
in some sense where markets come in two
places where people were addressing
poverty like for example microfinance
right the issue of mission drift in
microfinance there's a lot of commentary
going on there's a ton of data there's
just not a lot study yeah but to find
out what are the antecedents where
organizations adopting a for-profit
model are able to simultaneously persist
in a commitment to alleviating poverty
those things aren't naturally you know
go hand in hand but they do go hand and
hand in certain cases so I think it's
incumbent upon people like myself to
understand kind of what are the
antecedents whereby we do get you know
the best of what a market yo has to
offer and then one of the things we want
to work on I worry about when we set a
stand back and said I say listen you
don't want to see the whole lot of
market activity in that way because I'll
tell you the kind of outcomes that we'll
see so that's the exciting thing except
where two years into it in the business
school I think the next three to five
years are going to be awesome and like I
said for the for all the reasons you
know Emory just as this is this amazing
place I get access to things that
should I have no business get access to
your kind of based on my experience
profile because of the network of people
that were in so I just I'm really
excited about it sexy opportune time the
preceding program is copyrighted by
emory university